[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMY SHAMUS: All right.
Let's get started.
Thank you guys so
much for coming.
I'm so excited.
It's definitely my
honor and privilege
to introduce our two guests
today, Catherine, Dr. Birndorf
of the Motherhood
Center, and chief content
officer of Goop, Elise Loehnen.
I am Amy Shamus.
I'm on the events and
experience team here at Google.
I've been at Google
almost seven years,
but with two maternity
leaves back to back.
So it feels long,
but there is a chunk
missing as I started my
other career as a mom.
But we're here today
because I actually
saw Elise interview Dr. Birndorf
at the In Goop Health Summit
in January in New York City.
And she was on a panel, and I
was sitting in the audience.
My son was seven and a half
months old at the time,
and everything you
were saying resonated
with me, which I'm sure
a lot of you here, same,
as we'll be hearing
more from you.
And then I thought--
I ran up to Elise at
the end of the summit.
I said, we've got to
do something at Google.
And then life got in the
way, and it took me a while.
But you had your podcast.
And it was the third
ever Goop podcast,
and you deep dove on this
conversation of postpartum
anxiety, postpartum
depression, and what
you're calling the motherhood
shift, which I love.
And that was it.
That was the sign for me.
I said, let's get
these ladies to Google.
A lot of people will
want to hear from you
and talk about
this these issues.
We're very fortunate
at Google because we
have a wonderful benefits
team and a great paid
maternal and paternal leave.
But that's not to say that
Google isn't a very exhausting
and demanding place to
work, as it should be.
We are Google.
But there is a lot
to be learned when
we are in this post-baby,
postpartum phase, which
is why I thought that not only
myself would love to learn
more, and as I already said
to you guys, become your best
friends forever, but that
everyone else would learn
a lot about this
particular issue
and how we can work
through these changes
while we're at work.
And I would of course be remiss
if I didn't mention that May
is mental health month.
So Google is hosting
a series of talks
throughout the month
of May to dive deeper
into specific parts
of mental health.
And I know we're going to
address that a little bit
in our conversation today.
But just know that mental health
has a wide variety of looks
and feels, and
one in five people
suffer from some version of it.
So if there is
anything you're feeling
you need more out of Google
and from our benefits team,
be sure to look things up this
month on Go Mental Health,
and look out for different
talks throughout the rest
of the month.
So with all of that
said, let's get to going.
So again, I have two young boys.
I've only been back from
my second maternity leave
for seven and a
half months, which
feels so short yet so long.
And navigating being a
working mom is difficult.
And it was so wonderful
when I was hearing
that not only anecdotally it was
difficult, but scientifically
and biologically, it
is in fact difficult.
So while I had very high
functioning pregnancies
and postpartum experiences,
that was not the case,
certainly, for all
of my mommy friends.
And so I want to
just start today
with asking what is
postpartum anxiety?
What is postpartum depression?
What's the difference?
And then also, I
know you're kind
of coining a new term in that
sphere, so starting there.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Starting there, OK.
AMY SHAMUS: And that'll
be the whole hour.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
[INAUDIBLE] Keep it short.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Well,
I think postpartum is just
after birth, right.
So everybody is postpartum
once they have a kid.
And there's a normal range
of adjustment, right.
So we were just
talking about this.
Everybody has something.
It doesn't have to go all
the way to a disorder, right.
So what you're referring to is
what we're calling perinatal
mood and anxiety
disorders, PMAD,
[? P-MADs. ?] And that is
the new phrase for PPD,
which people are starting,
thankfully, to recognize.
Postpartum depression, that's
sort of the catch all phrase,
or postpartum.
People say, did you
have postpartum?
And that's in that
sort of whisper.
That's beyond the adjustment,
beyond the normal adjustment.
But it doesn't
capture it all, right.
So people are missed
because they think,
postpartum depression?
I'm not depressed.
So they get confused.
And so that's why
when you guys, when
Goop wanted to
talk about anxiety,
I thought it was great.
It's not new.
It just wasn't discussed.
So there can be normal--
look, when you have a kid,
everyone gets-- things change.
And I think we are very
adaptive, thankfully.
And so everyone's a
little bit anxious,
because you're taking
care of this totally
dependent creature.
You may not know how.
You probably don't know how.
And you have to figure it out.
And so everyone's a
bit anxious, but when
it goes beyond just
anxiety, that you
can get to work, do your things,
do your normal daily routines,
then we're getting into trouble.
And that may be in the anxious
realm or in a depressive realm.
And I can blather on
forever about those things.
So just know it's normal to have
a little bit of an adjustment.
How could you not?
It's the most profound
identity shift imaginable.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah, I remember--
this is an all too intimate
story, I'm sure,
but when I was--
see my poor husband
sitting in the audience.
But I was, I think,
three or four weeks
postpartum with my oldest son.
And I was so happy.
And I ran up to him,
just hysterical sobs,
hugging him saying it was
the happiest I'd ever been.
But yet I was--
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Crying.
AMY SHAMUS: --crying.
And I even said, once
I lose the baby weight,
this'll be the best ever.
And I mean, I look
back on it now like,
what was going on there?
And again, I was so happy.
So it wasn't anything to be
concerned about at the time.
But the emotions are--
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Intense.
AMY SHAMUS: --certainly
there and so intense.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Well,
that's the blues, right.
And that's almost everybody.
I say to patients
and to friends,
you're the unusual person
who doesn't have that.
You described it perfectly.
Happy, sad, we call it emotional
lability, sort of the ups
and downs, super intense.
And you feel like you're losing
your mind for that moment
or for those few minutes.
But you're not.
That's the hormonal
fluctuation that
is happening after delivery.
AMY SHAMUS: And
completely normal.
Just biologically--
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Totally normal.
AMY SHAMUS: --what happens.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Absolutely.
AMY SHAMUS: Which is, again,
what is so wonderful to hear.
And normal's not the
right word, but--
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Typical.
AMY SHAMUS: --to know that--
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Common.
Happens to almost everybody.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah.
So talk about the Motherhood
Center, which opened
in New York City, how long ago?
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Just over a year.
AMY SHAMUS: A year
ago, hopefully a
to be opening offices all over.
And just to note for people--
I know a bunch of you
who had emailed me--
it's not just for people
who are currently pregnant--
which if you are,
congratulations--
or if you just had a
baby, but if you are
thinking about having a baby.
So talk about the Motherhood
Center, what it is,
and how it helps.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: So we
opened this place called
the Motherhood Center,
which is trying
to help women and families
trying to conceive,
thinking about conceiving,
so fertility issues,
those who are pregnant, and
then those in the postpartum.
So it's really the
perinatal experience.
That's what that
time frame is, right.
And I know we're called
the Motherhood Center,
but as I see men out there
and I know who are dads,
I think, we really
do, we also address--
it's really a family issue,
and I think maybe we'll
talk some of that later.
But it's not just about the mom.
But we really wanted a
place where we could--
we've sort of turned ourselves
into the mothering center.
So we're really helping women
go through the adjustment
and the transition
into motherhood.
And the dads come on
Fridays, or the partners.
And we have a group
for just them.
And we also bring them
into different kinds
of family groups
so that they can
talk about their experience
in this transition.
But we go from-- just
to tell you a bit,
it's a comprehensive
treatment center.
Nothing like this
exists in the country.
So we're trying to
create this pilot program
that we hope we can
nail, so that we
can make it a
place that could be
in other areas of
the country, helping
women adjust to motherhood.
But it's not just those
who are well and having
the normal adjustment.
We are also dealing
with women who
are just shy of going
into the hospital, right,
so who are really needing a
comprehensive day program.
They're just not
making it out there.
They're not getting
out of the house.
prenatal care.
They're not going to their
pediatricians afterwards,
or just not able to function
as well as they should.
And these are high
functioning women who
just are so down or so anxious.
We see a lot of postpartum OCD.
That's one of the postpartum
anxiety disorders.
We see all kinds of things.
And they're just not--
they're not making it.
And so they come in for
therapies, group therapies,
from 9:45 to 2:45.
And we have an on-site nursery,
so they bring the babies,
and we help them kind of figure
out how to be with a baby.
Are they too attached?
Are they not-- are
they too detached?
So different iterations
of bonding and attachment
we address with the new moms.
AMY SHAMUS: It's so amazing.
How's it going?
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
It's going really well.
It's so much fun.
And I think those of
us who've come together
are so passionate about this
time period and treatment that
is so lacking.
There's a dearth of this kind
of treatment in the country.
And I think that to see women
go from struggling so much
and feeling like
they're never going
to be able to be the mother
they want to be, to within two
to four to six weeks, walking
out of there confident
and feeling like they got this--
we have graduates
come back and talk
to the moms who are newly coming
in, and it is like goosebumps.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah.
And you said it.
Certainly, the passion is there.
Even in just meetings
at Google, once you
identify that somebody
else is a mom, it is--
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Connection.
AMY SHAMUS: There's an
immediate switch and connection.
And people are so
passionate about this topic,
and feeling empowered is
difficult during the postpartum
time frame.
So Elise, to you, also
a mom of two boys.
ELISE LOEHNEN: Yeah.
AMY SHAMUS: Boy moms.
Girl moms are great.
Everything-- it's all good.
Babies are all good.
But you are the chief
content officer of Goop.
You have to see so much
come across your desk.
So how did you sift out
Catherine and the Motherhood
Center and say,
this is something
that we need to promote?
This is so brand right.
The synergy is so great.
What was it that
struck you about this
that's different than everything
else I'm sure you see?
ELISE LOEHNEN: So before--
actually, I wish I
had met Catherine
when I had my first child.
I'm sad that I didn't.
It would've been different.
I was not-- like
everyone, I don't
know anyone who's well
equipped for parenthood.
Definitely not well equipped.
And after I had my first
child, I felt really bad.
It was probably a
year after, and I
was talking to a doctor, this
doctor, Alejandro Junger.
And I was like,
what's wrong with me?
I don't feel good.
I'm tired of being
told that it's
because I have a
child, because I
was getting really good sleep.
And he put me on
his clean program.
He was like, let's get you
more vitamin D. He's just
like, I'm just going
to put something
based on what I think
is probably going on,
vitamin B, clean program.
I felt incredible.
I felt dramatically
better six weeks later.
And in that process, he
introduced me to this doctor
in the Australian bush.
His name's Oscar
Serrallach, and he
was working on this concept
called postnatal depletion.
And he was like,
there's just nothing
in literature about this.
But he was observing
it in this family
clinic in rural
Australia, these women who
would have multiple
children, and every time
they would present, they were
more depleted, more run down.
And he was like,
this is so weird.
There's stuff on postpartum
depression, not enough.
And then there's
nothing about depletion.
And I did a story with him,
and it was incredibly--
the response was insane.
Women were-- just
tons of emails.
Because essentially, he
believes for seven to 10 years--
it can take seven to
10 years to recover.
Women start in the sort
of depleted state already.
Even if you have the best
intention to eat perfectly,
I don't know anyone who does,
and our food is not amazing.
And you start behind
the starting block.
You have a child.
They take everything
that they need from you,
all the fat in your brain.
And you end up worse off.
And we all know
from having a baby
that you go to the
doctor a lot, and then
as soon as you have the
baby, no one cares about you.
You have like one check up
where they're like, looks fine.
I think your abs
aren't separated.
You can have sex
with your husband.
See you in a year.
And so anyway, this story,
people were like, this is me.
This is describing
the last decade
of my life, this
profound resonance.
And we were like,
wow, we really need
to talk more about
what's happening.
Because I think there's
a world of mom blogs,
and there's this perception
issue of people being like,
this is me and my perfectly
swaddled clothed child,
and I'm doing great.
And the reality that women
everywhere are struggling,
and then the whole--
the psychological part
came in through Birndorf
and the spectrum.
And we had a mom at Goop
who was really struggling.
She wouldn't mind me sharing
that, but just extreme panic
attacks.
She had had anxiety before.
She was great during
her pregnancy,
and then was not postpartum
depression, but OCD, anxiety,
to the extent that she
was like, I'm certifiable.
I need the hospital.
I need--
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
She couldn't function.
ELISE LOEHNEN:
Could not function.
And so Birndorf quarterbacked
her to function, I'd say.
She's doing great.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
ELISE LOEHNEN: So that's sort
of the long-- it was just like,
this needs to be something
that we talk about culturally.
AMY SHAMUS: So you're
truly filling a void.
There isn't anything else.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
There's nothing.
AMY SHAMUS: That's incredible.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: There
are individuals out there.
I have colleagues
across the country who
are doing this kind of
work, who are amazing,
who are in the field of
reproductive and perinatal
psychiatry, psychology.
But they're all
sort of individuals.
I mean, they tend to be in big
cities like my good friends
in LA and Chicago and New York.
But they're not-- we wanted to
create a center of community
where we could really
be the experts in this
and try to figure it out, right.
We have a lot of creative
space to do that.
We're a startup.
So we were a group of
passionate clinicians
who came together
trying to fill a need,
sort of solve for
something that is missing,
because we weren't
getting it done.
And I come from the academic
world, the ivory tower.
Can't even-- people
would say to me,
my phone number on
the internet is still
from when I was a
resident before now.
So it's ridiculous.
You can't even get the--
So it's hard.
It's a very fortressed
world out there.
Medicine, you know
it from your family,
but if you don't know
someone in the field,
it's very hard to break in.
And then you get
to mental health.
Forget physical
health, hard enough.
Mental health?
And that's why May, this
month, is so important
to talk about it.
I mean, nobody wants
to talk about this.
The fact that you'll even
say you had this hard time
postpartum is novel.
I mean, yes, celebrities
are coming out.
They're talking about it,
which I think is great.
It's definitely-- the word on
the street, it's out there.
But again, it's
getting mistaken as,
oh, I don't have depression.
I didn't have that
postpartum depression.
It used to be, I would say
five, 10 years ago, when
I would get calls, it would be
somebody killed their child,
right--
AMY SHAMUS: It was very extreme.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
--their infant, right.
And everyone thought that
was postpartum depression.
AMY SHAMUS: That's not.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: That's not.
That is postpartum psychosis,
when you lose touch
with reality and you
have these thoughts
that you're saving your
child if you kill them,
because you're so bad.
These are delusions.
This is a person
who is out of touch
with reality, because
as I always say,
no mother in their right mind
would hurt their child, right.
That's not--
So no one talks about it,
because they're like, oh,
if I tell anyone.
I mean, there was a
Sacramento story not long ago
where a woman told someone
in the pediatrician's
office or OB's office,
and they called the cops.
And then the cops-- then it
became a-- or ACS comes in,
Adult Child Services.
No one knows what's
going to happen if they
admit that they're struggling.
They think, they're going
to think I'm a bad mom.
They're going to think I'm
a bad person, that I might
try and hurt my kid, like those
horrible, sensationalized news
stories I've heard about.
So the fact that we're having
just a conversation about
routine stuff that I cannot--
one in five women
struggle, and dads too.
ELISE LOEHNEN: That has
to be under reported.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: I totally--
well, the number's one in seven.
I go with one in five,
because for sure, it's
under reported, under diagnosed,
under treated, and dads too.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah.
Well, I think what's amazing--
and this is moving a bit away
from Motherhood Center, but
obviously tangentially tied
to it and somebody
else that was on Goop--
"The Clarity Cleanse,"
so wonderful book
if you haven't read it.
I forget the author's name.
ELISE LOEHNEN: Habib Sadeghi.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah.
And he was actually at
the first Goop Summit.
I'm a Goop fan, if
you couldn't tell.
Next summit is in
three weeks, June 9.
Be there, LA.
But he talks about
actually, the mental health
and physical health
are the same thing.
And so while we're
still working to get
there and de-stigmatize
mental health, all of that
is so closely tied to
everything inside your body.
And so if you're
holding onto something
from the past
mentally, there will
be a physical manifestation
of it at some point.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
There's a great book
by a trauma expert,
Bessel van der Kolk called
"The Body Keeps a Score."
And I just love the title,
because I feel like it says it
all, right.
You don't escape your past.
You don't escape your mind,
your body, your trauma.
Everyone's got something.
It lives in the body,
and it will come out.
ELISE LOEHNEN: Or the mind.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Or the mind.
ELISE LOEHNEN: To channel
our other favorite parenting
expert, Robin Berman, becoming
a parent creates a crisis to you
because it forces the way you
were parented to the surface.
And suddenly, it's like,
what kind of mother
am I going to be?
What kind of mothering
did I not get?
Just a total--
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Crisis.
ELISE LOEHNEN:
Yeah, it's a crisis.
And I don't think people
are necessarily even--
they're not conscious of that.
AMY SHAMUS: No.
Sometimes you are.
I mean, I think with
"Permission to Parent,"
which is a wonderful book
if you haven't read it--
and you just so happen to be
the author's best friend, which
is adorable.
My husband I talk
about this often with,
we try to create for our boys
the opposite of what we had.
But as we're in the midst of
seeing all of our friends also
become parents, it's very
interesting because some
of them just directly
want to copy that,
because they had such
wonderful-- so they
seem-- idyllic childhoods.
But it is an act of
becoming a parent,
and you chose it the
minute you got pregnant.
But it isn't something that is
fully fleshed out in your brain
until you start seeing these
little things run around.
ELISE LOEHNEN: And
then there's this idea
that it's all supposed
to be natural, right.
Like, there is no act
and you're supposed
to know how to breastfeed,
and I mean, these things
that are not natural.
I'm sorry, but like--
And what's a natural birth?
And that conversation
drives me nuts too.
And it starts, the
judgment starts--
I mean, what kind of birth
are you going to have?
I mean, not to just--
I'm not complaining
just to complain.
But it's complicated.
AMY SHAMUS: But
I also think too,
that's another thing about going
back to, when you're pregnant,
you are the princess, and
once you have the baby,
you're the peasant.
Even with when you had the
lactation consultant come,
I remember I thought
this was for me,
because it was so painful
and so hard the first time.
And they're like, nope,
nope, all about the baby.
I'm like, but what--
how do I-- no,
can I get some
help over here too?
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Culturally,
we've missed the boat.
We've missed the boat.
And again, that's why what we're
finding when these women leave
the Motherhood Center
is they are repleted,
to go back to that
depleted word.
They feel cared for, nourished.
We do not do that for moms.
AMY SHAMUS: No.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
It's all about the baby.
You're celebrated when
you're pregnant, right,
but the minute that kid's
out, all eyes on the baby.
And great, but
what about the mom?
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah, and I
hope there is a shift.
I mean, at least, again,
in my small circle,
we always do, when
a baby's born,
it's not about
holding that new baby.
It's, where's your laundry?
And what can I do for you?
Because I will Mary Poppins
this, because that's selfishly
what I would like to have.
But it is, you don't
know until you know.
And it's, but how do we educate?
So obviously Motherhood
Center, but Elise,
what other opportunities
are out there?
I guess opportunity's
the wrong word.
But what other things
are in place for women
to go to and get this
sort of resource?
Obviously, if we can't
all be in New York City,
which, as Googlers, we're
lucky because we potentially
do work in New York.
And we can visit, and we will.
But for those of us who can't,
digital's key right now.
So what resources are out there,
other than Goop, of course?
ELISE LOEHNEN: Other than Goop
and hopefully more Motherhood
Centers too, I mean, I
wouldn't-- it's hard to say.
I mean, I'd say it's
piecing together
things that work for you.
And a lot of it, it's
like we can learn a lot
from the airline industry.
You have to put the oxygen
mask on yourself first
before you help other people.
And I think it's a
familial conversation.
I think it's a forced
conversation with partners
too of like, I need to be
as prioritized as my child.
And that needs to be
a social conversation.
That needs to be the
cultural conversation of--
We were talking
about this before.
I'm married to a
really lovely man.
He's great.
He has a far less
stressful career,
and he's a really good dad.
I still do 60% of the work.
And he is applauded.
He is celebrated
as an amazing dad,
because sometimes he drops
our kid off at preschool
and he puts them to bed.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
No anger there.
ELISE LOEHNEN: Yeah.
And I am not celebrated.
I'm an absent mom, even
though I do more of the work.
And so it's even just
bringing awareness to that.
And then I think
in order for things
to change, it's connecting with
women who are not yet mothers,
because nobody knows.
I just was shocked.
It was before I was at Goop,
but when I had my first child,
and I was eight months pregnant,
and I went to the benefits
office for my matern--
and I was like, oh,
so I'll be on maternity leave.
And she was like, OK,
so you'll be paid--
and this is far better than
vast majority of Americans--
we're going to pay
you for six weeks,
and then you go on disability.
I was like, I can't
survive on disability.
What are you talking about?
I thought I had a 12 week leave.
And I think 27% of women are
back at work two weeks after
having a baby because
they have no family leave.
And then you start this whole
cycle, a pernicious cycle.
And I was furious.
I was so mad, not
only at my company,
but also at the culture.
And that's not a
good way to start--
that's not a good way
to become a mom either.
AMY SHAMUS: That's
not good for anyone.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: It's funny.
I was a resident when I had
my first kid, who's now 19,
and I didn't know
what I got either.
And I'm like, huh,
I don't even know
if there's maternity leave.
I was one of the
few residents to get
pregnant during
residency in those years.
And I went in, and I'm
like, what's the deal?
And they said, six weeks.
And if you have a
C-section, you'll get eight.
This is at a hospital, right.
I mean, it's so ironic.
It was dismal.
AMY SHAMUS: Well, I will
say, to Google's credit--
ELISE LOEHNEN: I know.
You guys win.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
You guys do it right.
AMY SHAMUS: We have an
incredible maternity
and paternity leave policy.
And for those of you
thinking about getting
pregnant, thinking, I don't
need all that, you need it all.
Take it all.
There's never a day you'll
wish you didn't do that.
But we also-- and I said
when I opened this talk,
the expectation when
you're working here
is incredibly high.
And it is so
difficult to be a mom
and have all of
those expectations.
So I agree with you that
it starts with women
who haven't had children.
And I have a lovely manager, and
he's so responsive to my needs.
I force it, because I always
have these conversations
with him.
But not everyone is like that.
But I find it to be a
little trickier with peers
who don't have children.
So I mean, I'm
sure you've seen--
New York City, you've got
to have some high powered
ladies coming in there.
So what is some advice to help
moms in high powered jobs deal
with women that don't have
kids, who may want to?
And it's no one's fault, but
it is an interesting place
to navigate with when
you get that call.
Yesterday, my son, we had
to take him to the doctor
unexpectedly at 2:30 PM, and
so I had to work from home.
And it's very difficult.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Well,
it's a systemic issue, right.
And we look at it as
the mother's problem.
I'm not sure if dads are running
home as much or partners are
running home.
But the primary
caretaker, whoever
that is, typically the mom,
is really disadvantaged,
which should not be the case.
This is a fam--
I mean, do we want to
populate this country?
I--you know.
But so isn't this
everyone's issue?
Isn't it a natural thing?
So why it's
considered a problem--
and everyone's hiding.
Can you cover for
me while I run out?
It's like, what?
So again, it's hard,
but I think that it has
to be a community, a familial.
We have to-- it's a
cultural, systemic issue.
AMY SHAMUS: And you're right.
Even yesterday,
I kind of cowered
when I said, well, I've got
to take him to the doctor,
because he might
have bronchitis.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
You should be there.
You should be able to
go, or your partner
should be able to go.
That's normal.
Normal, we were using that word.
AMY SHAMUS: And you're right.
I mean, it is
difficult for people,
but I think the verbiage
around it is so important.
ELISE LOEHNEN: Well,
and I think honestly,
it's an issue that needs
to start with men, I think.
One, when you look
at the research,
they have the power
to advocate change.
And I think they feel shy about
it, like it's a woman's issue
and it's not really my place.
But it's sadly, going
to be the most well--
they can--
AMY SHAMUS: It's a numbers game.
They just--
ELISE LOEHNEN: It's
a numbers game.
Women and minorities, when
they advocate for themselves,
it doesn't always go well.
Men, when they advocate,
are seen as big hearted.
It's positive.
So men need to start
advocating for it.
They need to make sure that
there are women in the room.
They need to model it and make
sure that that environment is
one that is ideally--
and this, it only works in
places like Goop and Google--
but that they're setting
reasonable work hours
and not inundating
people on the weekends,
and letting mothers
in particular
do their work when
they can do their work.
I mean, if you want
something done, ask a mom.
I don't know any mom--
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: A busy mom.
ELISE LOEHNEN: Yeah,
who falls down on that.
But it has to start.
It has to be that
sort of conversation.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Do the men take it?
I'm wondering, at
Goop and at Google,
do they take maternity,
or paternity?
Because I think that that's
another issue, is that they're
eh, they'll take a week or two.
And again, I don't
mean to stereotype,
but are they modeling it?
Are they taking it, or
are they seen as somehow
weaker if they actually use it?
AMY SHAMUS: So I don't
know the stats on that.
I'm sure we can get it.
But I do know that my husband,
he works for a different tech
company, and he did take
his two paternity leaves.
Thank you very much.
That's a gift
we'll all certainly
never want to give back.
And I know my brother-in-law
works at Google,
and will be taking
his paternity leave.
So it certainly
is becoming more--
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
It's encouraged.
AMY SHAMUS: It's
certainly encouraged.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: The
culture encourage-- well,
you guys are the cutting edge.
I mean, you are leading the way.
AMY SHAMUS: But even for us--
and I am much more glass half
full, so I see us as being--
it's such a wonderful
experience in the amount of time
we get off.
But even two weeks
ago when my son was--
who turned one, there
was a gal in Canada
who I was chatting with.
And her son also
just turned one,
and she just got back
from maternity leave.
And she too works at Google.
So it is very interesting.
And I certainly am so
happy to have what we have,
but it isn't perfect.
And what is the right amount
of time for a woman to have off
is obviously
different per woman.
But we should have a
larger spectrum of--
ELISE LOEHNEN: That's the thing.
I mean, I'm, in some ways, not
maybe a good representative.
But when I had my
second child, it was--
this'll probably
drive you crazy.
It was an incredibly busy time,
and I just brought him to work.
I stayed home for
six weeks, and then
I just brought my baby to
work for eight weeks, I think.
And it was awesome.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Did anybody care?
ELISE LOEHNEN: No,
everyone loved it.
I mean, he just was
like the office baby.
He'd be napping in
everyone's arms.
I'd nurse him at work.
And sure, if it had
been a different time,
I would have stayed
away for longer.
But that worked for
me, and what also
works for me is if I
need to go to the doctor,
I go to the doctor
without guilt.
Or he goes to a
co-op nursery school,
so I work at the school
one day a month, et cetera.
That's what I need, is prolonged
and constant flexibility.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
That's the word.
ELISE LOEHNEN: Yeah.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
That's the word.
ELISE LOEHNEN: And I
definitely get my job done,
but it has to be within the
confines of a flexible--
and I am fine with that for
my whole team, many of whom
are not moms.
I'm like, I don't care
if you are in Alaska
and your work is done.
Like--
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Fine.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah,
more power to you.
Yeah, flexibility
is certainly key.
So before I open up
to Q&A, because I'm
sure a lot of people
have questions,
and we have some questions that
will be coming from online,
one of my last
questions is how do we
de-stigmatize or normalize
postpartum anxiety
or postpartum depression?
How can we make it a more
welcome environment for women
to talk about it,
not only at a center
or behind closed doors with
their managers or girlfriends?
Is it simply just
talking about it?
Is it men talking about it?
Is it women without
children talking about it--
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Everybody.
AMY SHAMUS: --because
they've seen it?
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Talking, talking, talking.
Cannot talk enough about
it to help people feel--
to normalize the
transition, that it's hard,
to validate their
varied experiences.
It's different for everyone.
But talking is key, and in
a non-judgmental way, right.
There's no judgment,
right, whether you
work outside the home or
work inside, wherever it is.
People are different,
and we want
to respect their different
experiences vis a vis
motherhood, parenthood.
And so just in a way, just
being curious, right asking,
how's it going for you?
I always say, doctors don't
like to not know answers.
And they'll say, well,
I don't ask women
about postpartum
anxiety or depression
because I don't treat it.
I'm not the expert like you.
I don't know what to do.
And I said, oh god, we
have a long way to go.
But you don't have to know what
scales, what questions to ask.
Just look them in the
eye, hold their gaze,
and say, how are you?
And don't move,
and look at them.
And often people
burst into tears.
They'll be like, no one's
asked how I am, right.
It's all about this
cute little baby, right.
But you've got to just
look someone in the eye,
just have a real
conversation, not like hey,
how are you doing, oh
it's great, right, right.
Wrong.
Just have the conversation.
Just have a real conversation.
AMY SHAMUS: I
absolutely love that.
And I was talking to a teammate
of mine about something
very similar with just ask.
You might feel uncomfortable or
you might not know what to ask,
but just do exactly
what you said.
A few months ago, I was
listening to the Oprah Winfrey
podcast and she was
interviewing Sheryl Sandberg.
And she was talking about--
obviously her husband died,
and people were, with
trepidation, circling
the issue.
And she said, I'm always
thinking about it,
so you can always ask me.
And while this,
becoming a mother,
is a much happier thing,
but you can always
ask me how I'm doing
because I'm always
thinking about my children.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: And you
don't have to know what to say.
That's the thing.
You can even say, I don't
really know how to ask you this,
but I know you're--
AMY SHAMUS: How are you doing?
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Yeah, how are you doing?
And you don't have
to know the answer.
You can Google it.
ELISE LOEHNEN: We
do something at Goop
on occasion for meetings where
we just quickly go around
the room and people say,
either personal and work,
or combination, or
however you want to do it,
are you red, yellow, green.
And it's very helpful just to,
one-- and people can explain,
or they don't have to explain.
But I think it also,
in any context--
it gives greater context
to any interaction of just
like, I might be red, because
maybe I was up all night
with a sick kid.
And it I might not be in a
great mood, and it's not you.
But I think it also creates a--
it's important what
happens at home,
and the two are so
intermingled now.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah, and also
at home when you get home
with asking your partner.
You red, yellow, or green?
OK, any questions
in the audience?
OK, too shy?
We've got some on the Dory.
ELISE LOEHNEN: We just
answered everyone's questions.
AMY SHAMUS: I know.
No, we have lots coming.
So OK, first one on here.
"What can husbands do
to support their spouse
when they're suffering
from postpartum depression?
Even later, when my wife
seems to have come out of it
but isn't 100% of
her earlier self,
can I do anything to make
her feel better, outside
of the medical help she
is and was getting?"
Great question.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Awesome question.
I think you can ask.
People don't often, or won't,
volunteer what they need.
But I'll often say,
we're not mind readers.
Ask.
How can I help you?
What can I do for you?
And observe.
See what she's struggling
with, where are areas
in which you can be helpful.
But you may not know.
You know the love languages?
You may not know what would
feel cared for for her
and vise versa.
So you're asking.
So what can I do to help you?
You don't seem
entirely yourself.
What am I missing?
What are we not doing here?
Are you getting-- are there
ways in which you can help
her get to the help she needs?
Is she getting
mental health help?
Are the needs being met?
Because you can feel--
with proper treatment,
everyone feels better,
and everyone gets well.
And a lot of times,
women will say,
I feel even better
than I ever felt.
Because maybe they had
a simmering depression
or they'd always been
chronically anxious,
and it didn't come to light
until they were postpartum,
and then it just blew up.
So I think sometimes
with proper treatment,
you really can be even better.
So if that's not the
case, continue to persist.
Don't ever give up.
If you feel like your
wife's come out of it,
but is not quite there,
just don't give up.
Keep pushing until you get
to a place that feels right,
feels comfortable.
AMY SHAMUS: Great question.
OK.
"Coming back to work with
postpartum depression
is very hard, but
often times colleagues
don't know what they can do.
What would you recommend
for manager colleagues
to do to help?"
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: These
are really good questions.
I wish I could ask that per--
I don't know if
they can hear me.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah,
they can everything.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: OK.
Do people know?
I mean, that's the thing.
Are you, who's asking the
question, willing to share?
Again, we're sharers
up here, clearly.
And I don't know that you
have to give all the details,
but I think if you're
willing-- again,
this is part of what brings it
out, is to say, I struggled.
You don't have to give--
just I struggled,
or I'm struggling.
And then your manager--
and then you can
think about ways
to assist your
manager helping you.
It would be great if
you could help me with,
or if I could run out to a
pediatrician or appointment,
or you know what, I'm actually
getting treatment for my blank.
Would it be OK with you if I
left for these appointments,
right.
You have to ask.
And you have to teach.
You have to help
people help you.
So I think that if you're
willing to share-- and again,
you don't have to go
down to the TMI rabbit
hole of every detail, but
just, I've been struggling.
So would it be OK if, right.
And anyone says no to that?
I mean.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Yeah.
Great question.
"Could you recommend lifestyle
best practices, specifically
diet, nutrition,
supplements, exercise,
et cetera, to help
replenish moms?"
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: That's you.
You're the queen of that.
ELISE LOEHNEN: I know.
I'm the doctor on this platform.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: You're
the lifestyle [INAUDIBLE]
ELISE LOEHNEN: Yeah.
So generally, my advice would
be to get your doctor, or go--
what's it called, One Medical?
AMY SHAMUS: So One Medical here.
Again, fortunately for us,
Google has amazing benefits.
And One Medical is now
our wellness center.
So I'm sure you're going to
say, get your panel tested.
ELISE LOEHNEN: Get
your panel tested.
AMY SHAMUS: Which I
did, and you can do.
ELISE LOEHNEN: Yeah,
so most likely, I mean,
omegas, so like
really good fish oil.
You can't really take
too much of that.
Vitamin D, vitamin B, magnesium,
iron, that's probably baseline.
And then you get your
hormones checked.
Make sure your thyroid
is functioning.
And you'll want to
work with your doctor
to address it or tinker with it
if it's not, because that can--
a lot of autoimmune disease
flares up postnatally
for women, and you
want to curb it.
There's this autoimmune
spectrum that a lot of doctors
are starting to talk about.
Like, you don't
get that diagnosis
of Hashimoto's until
you've essentially
destroyed your thyroid.
But there are a
lot of things you
can do in the interim to help.
Exercise, it's really hard.
Exercise is really
hard for new moms.
You're nursing, you're
leaking, you're incontinent.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: It's so fun.
ELISE LOEHNEN: It's so awesome.
And I'd say I would try to find
someone who can really help you
with your pelvic floor.
I am from Goop, guys.
And in Europe, it's mandated.
You get an app.
They are getting your pelvic
floor back into shape.
But I would definitely
focus on that,
because you don't want
a prolapsed uterus
or bladder later in
life, and you definitely
want to be able
to hold your pee.
You can jump on a Rebounder too.
That's really helpful.
But there are a lot
of physical therapists
who will work on your pelvic
floor and also help you--
like for me, because
I came to Goop
after I became a
mom, like a year out,
I went to work with this
woman, Lauren Roxburgh, who
does a lot of film
rolling content with us.
And I was still holding
myself like I was pregnant,
which is very common.
But just this--
I looked pregnant.
And so she got me
back into alignment,
which you can do through
Pilates or physical therapy.
But your organs are all
out of whack and stuff.
And your body will come
back, but you can help.
There are a lot of things
that you can do to help.
AMY SHAMUS: I'm by
no means expert,
but do read a lot of content.
And I would say, you
mentioned Alejandro Junger
who, eight years ago,
significantly changed my life.
My mom has an
autoimmune disease,
which is what brought me to
this whole wellness thing.
And doing the clean every
year I think is so important.
And I know it's so hard to get
your mind over not being able
to, for me, drink
alcohol-- well,
just wine-- but drink
a little bit of wine
and have a piece of pizza.
But it's 21 days.
You can certainly do it.
You have given birth.
You can do--
ELISE LOEHNEN: It's easy too.
AMY SHAMUS: --a 21-day cleanse.
ELISE LOEHNEN: And
it's nourishing.
It's not about deprivation.
It's not a calorie thing at all.
You can shove as much
stuff into your smoothies.
You can snack if you're hungry.
AMY SHAMUS: High fat, filling.
ELISE LOEHNEN: Yeah.
It's all about eliminating
potential things
that might be aggravating you.
So it's also really good
if you need to know,
am I tolerant of gluten?
Am I tolerant of dairy?
And there are supplements
that go with it.
For after my first one,
it profoundly shifted me,
and it reset.
I didn't lose--
I lost like two pounds
when I did it, 21 days.
And then after, I just
dropped all my weight.
It was weird.
It just reset me.
But I agree.
It's two shakes,
breakfast and dinner.
And it's actually
really nice not to have
to make dinner for 21 days.
AMY SHAMUS: And yeah,
he's just wonderful.
He has a lot of different
resources out there too.
So for diet, I would
strongly recommend his stuff.
ELISE LOEHNEN: He's the best.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah.
And then for exercise too,
what I found after my second,
especially right away, was
it was very hard to get out,
especially finding classes.
I'm a class person.
I love Orange Theory and
Bar Method and hot Pilates.
But how do I get
there if he's supposed
to be nursing at that
time and they're preset?
So I'm a big Bar Method fan.
And if you like bar,
I really, really
believe in it during pregnancy.
It just keeps everything
tight and nice,
and it's not too
strenuous on you.
But they have online classes.
And they're just as
good, I swear it.
I'm not the type of person
who can work out at home,
and this has really
changed for me, especially
because I travel for work.
ELISE LOEHNEN: YogaGlo,
I think you guys
have a program with them.
They're good.
There are a lot
of good streaming.
It's a good idea, YogaGlo,
Tracy Anderson, bar.
AMY SHAMUS: [INAUDIBLE] good.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Can I just say walking?
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah, walking.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
I'm a basic person.
ELISE LOEHNEN: What?
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Like
how am I doing the walk?
I mean, I live in New York
City, so you can walk to work.
Just walking, like get
those 10,000 steps in.
I'm so basic.
I can't--
AMY SHAMUS: No,
that's great, though.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
--barely do it.
I was going to say, and
for the others, sleep.
ELISE LOEHNEN: You can
do it with your baby too.
Strap that baby on.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah.
OK.
"I had significant
postpartum depression
and took short term disability
leave after my maternity leave.
Do you have advice
for sharing or not
sharing with colleagues why
I was on leave for so long?
My colleagues assume I extended
my maternity leave and was
'lucky,' quote unquote, when
my experience was terrible."
ELISE LOEHNEN: Oh my god.
Just invite them to
stay home with the baby.
I mean, even in
the best scenario.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Yeah.
I think that's very personal.
I think you have to decide
how much you're willing to put
yourself out there.
And again, I don't
think you have
to give all the information,
but if you're sensing
that people feel kind of--
are looking at you
kind of like, ugh, you
with the extra maternity
leave, you might,
if you have the
opportunity, or maybe you
make the opportunity
to address it, and say,
I had a really difficult time.
My extra leave really had
to do with a medical issue.
Again, postpartum
depression is a med--
mental illness is medical.
So this is a medical problem.
And when I write notes--
I do a lot of letters
for disability.
I may be a psychiatrist, but
these are medical problems.
And it has to be addressed as
such and considered as such.
And I think sharing that you
had a medical problem, which
was why you were out, you don't
have to go into the details--
again, you can choose how
much you want to share.
But I think
reconceptualizing this
as a medical issue is
important, because I think
that let's us off the hook.
I'm not just weak or
defective, but this is really--
it's a real thing.
And you can say as
much or as little,
but I think that's up to how
much you're willing to share.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah.
It's so hard not to be
ashamed by it, though.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Shame is-- ugh.
AMY SHAMUS: I know.
How do we get rid of that?
ELISE LOEHNEN: Conversation.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Yeah, we're doing it.
ELISE LOEHNEN: And
brave people, I
think, stepping up and
saying, this happened to me,
and let's talk about it.
Yeah, I know celebrities
are doing it.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Yeah, I think
the more we bring it into
general conversation,
the better, and
recognize that it's
a difficult time for anybody.
It's not love at first sight.
I mean, sometimes it
is, but a lot of times
it takes a while before you
kind of fall in love with a kid,
or know what to do,
or feel comfortable.
ELISE LOEHNEN: Do
you have postpartum--
are there support groups here?
AMY SHAMUS: I don't know.
ELISE LOEHNEN: Yeah?
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Ooh, excellent.
If not, we'll help you.
AMY SHAMUS: Do we have
a go-link for that?
Sorry, getting the benefits--
SPEAKER 1: There's
no [INAUDIBLE]..
If you just Google [? Mama ?]
Moms Support Group, though.
AMY SHAMUS: OK.
[? Mama ?] Mom's Support Group.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: It's so
important to find a cohort.
I think that it's
very validating.
And then the shame level goes
down, because you're like,
you had that?
You feel this way?
And because it's hard to do, and
it's hard to be in the park--
I always say, women in the
park, they don't mean to lie--
or Instagram, whatever.
Everyone looks good.
So it's hard to sort of break
through that veneer of what
you think.
You think everybody else
has it easier, better.
They know what to do.
And they're just as
terrified and unsure and--
AMY SHAMUS: Tired.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
And tired, and how you
get the conversation going.
So when you have a
moms group, hopefully,
it's a group where there's
honesty and authenticity, where
you can really share and
validate each other so that you
can say yeah, it's really hard.
ELISE LOEHNEN: And pre-sharing.
I think, too, I'm very vocal
about my experience as a mom.
And I feel like people need
to talk about it to people
who are pregnant or
thinking about it, being
like there's just some--
I mean, I was so mad at my
friends when I had my baby.
And I was like, why did no
one tell me this, any of this?
AMY SHAMUS: We didn't
want to scare you.
ELISE LOEHNEN:
Hemorrhoids, and--
you're like, heads up.
I could have-- sorry.
AMY SHAMUS: No, no.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: But that
goes for the emotional too.
AMY SHAMUS: Amen.
ELISE LOEHNEN: But no
one talks about it,
and so you are left,
again, in shame.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah, I
always say, I give--
ELISE LOEHNEN: Get the
Tucks pads in bulk.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah.
Well, do you see even
Chrissy Teigen just
posted right after she had
the second baby, Asian pear
underwear.
So the little mesh netting
sometimes you see on pears,
she put a picture of
herself postpartum
with the hospital underwear on.
And I mean, the comments
on it were just, yeah,
why is no one
talking about this?
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Well,
actually, a co-author and I
are writing a new book called
"How Come no One Told Me?"
because that is the refrain.
And it's the emotional side
of pregnancy and postpartum,
because no one talks about it.
So the idea is, all these
questions are actually
answered in the book.
We talk about from the
minute you're pregnant,
and what you don't know
and what you need to know.
It's the need to know stuff.
What "What to Expect"
did for the physical,
we want to do for the emotional.
AMY SHAMUS: And that comes out
to in a year, next Mother's
Day.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Yep, that's right.
2019.
AMY SHAMUS: Everybody
get planning on that.
I always say I'm
certainly somebody
that folks come to when
they're about to get pregnant
or they get--
and I've got the whole
email and everything.
I tailor it to
every single person,
but I always start it off with
saying, oh, it's the best.
It's the worst,
but it's the best.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: It's
the best and the worst.
ELISE LOEHNEN: It's
the craziest learning--
the learning curve is intense.
AMY SHAMUS: And the pendulum
swings some days really
quickly in between
those two things,
and sometimes stays for
longer in the euphoria.
But it is.
And if people care
to ask, I will say,
here's why it's the best, and
here's why it's the worst.
But oftentimes people
don't always want to know.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
And can they retain it?
That's the other
thing I always wonder,
because when I used to go give
lectures to the new parents
group, I had to bust my
way in in the hospital.
I would say, can I
come and just give
a little preview of what
postpartum might be like?
And they're like,
no, because we don't
want to scare those people.
Really?
We have to tell people what
it could be like, and not
think of that as--
I felt like the grim
reaper, as opposed to just,
this is just information.
AMY SHAMUS: Oh yeah,
just being honest.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Yeah.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah.
OK.
"At almost nine
months postpartum,
I still feel a loss
of time with my LO--"
ELISE LOEHNEN: Little one.
AMY SHAMUS: Little one, aww.
"--when I'm at work.
What can I do to feel
better about being at work?
Trying to rationalize it, I
need to work for my family,
but it's not helping with the
sadness of lost opportunity
cost, time with my baby."
ELISE LOEHNEN: Mm.
AMY SHAMUS: I know, so it's--
ELISE LOEHNEN: Yeah.
It's hard.
I mean, but it's also--
I always talk about how I
think about it for myself,
which I also definitely need
to work, and I do love to work.
One, I'm like, the
universe has created
enough of a support network
for me to be able to work,
and I'm going to lean into that.
I love my nanny.
She is like my mother,
everyone's mother.
And so that makes
me feel better,
that my child is
surrounded by love.
But also, I'm like,
I need to model.
I'm going to model
for my boys what
it is to have a mom who works.
I feel on some spiritual,
karmic-- like they chose me.
They get it.
And this might not be true
of you, but I am not--
I wasn't put here--
I'm not like a on the
floor, playing mom.
I've let myself off
the hook for that.
But also, I'm good at
work, and I'm a good mom.
And it's not perfect.
It doesn't look perfect,
but I think it's
allowing for the messiness.
And you have to let
yourself off the hook.
It's not lost opportunity.
It's like you are
also having a life.
You're showing your
kids that there's
more outside of the world than
them too, which is important.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: And I would
add quality over quantity.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Which
is cliche, but very true,
or at least I tell myself that.
And it sounds like--
I mean, it's important that
when you're with them-- look,
if you're with them and you're
lamenting the loss of time,
or you're having regret
when you're with them,
or you're so guilty
then there's a
different problem.
Then you've got to
address that, right.
You're not able to put it
aside and be with them.
So when you're there, be there.
And when you're at
work, be at work.
And you can still
be checking in,
but you have to be
present where you are.
And then when you're home
with them, be with them.
But if that's hard, then you
have to work through this,
because most people aren't
home with their kids.
I mean, in our country, two
working families is the norm.
And I don't think kids are
any worse off because of it.
I think to your point,
modeling and showing them.
I remember so distinctly when
my older daughter was four,
she was in the bathtub.
I was running to the hospital.
I was on call, and I said,
ugh, I have to go to work.
I'm so sorry to leave you.
And she looked at me and
said, why do you say that?
You like your job.
You like it.
And I thought, oh my god,
she let me off the hook.
And I thought, don't
do this to my kids.
Don't make them--
She's right.
I love what I do.
And I love to work,
and I love my kids,
and I love to be at
home when I'm at home.
But I would not be a
good stay at home mom.
I'd be a disaster.
ELISE LOEHNEN: Me too.
AMY SHAMUS: It's
the hardest job.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Hardest job.
I have such admiration.
And the women who
stay home and do this,
and want to do it and
love doing it, great.
It's just complicated.
You have to figure out whatever
the formula is for yourself,
and there's no right,
wrong, or perfection.
It's just you've got to
figure out what works
for you in your family context.
But the guilt, enough,
the regret, the shame.
It's so wasteful.
ELISE LOEHNEN: I went
to this moms group
after I had my first,
and she said something
that I really needed to hear.
And she was like, think
about your childhood
and your happiest memories.
And my happiest memories
were running wild
in the woods with my brother.
I grew up in Montana.
And she was like, how many
of your happiest memories
were your parents
in attendance for?
And not that many.
I have amazing parents,
and they were present.
But she was like, your
child, unfortunately, you
are at the center of
their world right now,
but their life extends
far beyond you.
And you don't need
to put yourself
in the center of their
story constantly.
They have their own
lives, which is difficult.
It kind of broke my heart,
but I needed to hear it.
AMY SHAMUS: And I will say
that we do have resources,
so if you are feeling
still really down about it
and missing your child,
to talk to your manager,
talk about a flexible
schedule if that's possible.
I agree with you.
We live in Bay
Area, New York, LA.
A double working
household is very common,
and yet the culture
hasn't kept up with it.
I always say,
school ends at 2:00?
Who's going to pick my kid--
work doesn't end at 2:00.
What is this all about?
So things hopefully
shift and change.
But there is
flexibility at Google,
so hopefully you can talk
to your manager about it.
Let's do one more and then
we can close things out.
So-- I know, I want to do
two more because the next one
looks really good.
But OK, "Can you
speak more to how
physical health and
lifestyle behaviors impact
mental health?"
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
So intertwined.
I think that it's probably
false that we separate them.
AMY SHAMUS: Oh, absolutely.
And that's what "The
Clarity Cleanse" is about.
So great question.
I would certainly read it.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Yeah, I think--
ELISE LOEHNEN: Vitamin B.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Vitamin B, right.
I think you want to be
physically well so and not so
stressed.
You want to minimize
stress, maximize self-care,
taking care of yourself.
It's not selfish.
It is self preserving,
self nourishing.
Like the oxygen mask, you're
no good to anybody else
if you're not OK.
But you're no good to yourself
if you're not physically well
enough, and I think that helps
you be as mentally well enough.
Again, you don't
have to be perfect.
Everything doesn't
have to be exact.
But I think that they're
just so intertwined
that you have to address both.
And I think that becomes a
problem, because people--
everyone knows to work
out, go to the gym.
I'll be walking.
Everyone else can be in the gym.
But mental health has
to also be addressed.
I said to someone the
other day, who said, wait,
is therapy like
gym for your mind?
It's like going to
the gym for your mind.
Yeah.
AMY SHAMUS: It's like
brushing your teeth.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Right?
So OK, not everyone's going
to go to therapy, though I
kind of think they should.
AMY SHAMUS: I agree.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: I think
almost anyone can use it,
because we all have pasts.
We all have baggage.
We all have things to work out,
so that we don't revisit them
on our children, as
we're talking about.
And I think that you want to be
as well emotionally, mentally,
as you can.
And that will help
your physical health.
They work in concert.
And to ignore one, or to
only focus on the other
is short sighted.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah.
And again with Google, go
to MoMA and look up Concern.
We have programs that we can
certainly get therapy sessions,
and it's really helpful.
I personally use it and
talk about it openly,
because I think
it's so important.
And there have been
many times when
I've been talking to my
husband and I'm like,
I'm on my way therapy.
I nothing to say.
And then I leave like, that was
the best session I've ever had.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: It's better
when you have nothing to say.
AMY SHAMUS: It is.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Can I
just put a plug in for that?
It's not about the content.
It's about everything else.
AMY SHAMUS: Yeah.
Anyway, so great
question, though.
And then last, "You mentioned
that this can affect dads too.
My husband has had severe
depression and anxiety
since the birth of our twins,
despite medication and therapy.
He feels very isolated.
What resources are
available for dads,
and what can I do
to help, especially
when I'm struggling myself?"
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Awesome question.
AMY SHAMUS: Great action.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: One
of my fellow board members
at Postpartum Support
International, Danny Singley,
this is his thing.
He's in San Diego, I think,
but he's Mr. postpartum dad.
He's a great guy and he
writes a ton about this.
And we also have somebody
at the Motherhood
Center, Chuck Schaeffer
who works with the dads.
It's really important.
Again, dads who are
struggling need a cohort.
They need other dads or other
partners who are struggling.
And they need the validation,
need the treatment.
It sounds like he's
getting some treatment.
But you need the resources.
So I'd say, going back
to that, postpartum.net.
That's the website
for Postpartum Support
International.
Dads are a big part
of it, families.
Again, it started about moms,
but it's really families.
And now we're big
into dads right,
into helping dads find
the resources they need.
There's a, I think it's a
weekly chat for dads online.
So you can be anywhere.
There are just great
resources on the website,
so postpartum.net.
Danny Singley, Chuck
Schaeffer, these
are some of the
guys who are writing
about it out there nationally.
And there are others who do it.
But again, search
for your community.
And to the mom who's
also struggling,
this is easy,
because sometimes you
can't even get online to
look for it if you're so
down and out.
So if you can find
those resources,
just help him get
to the resources.
A place like Postpartum Support
International will take it
from there, will help you.
ELISE LOEHNEN: And remember, I
think that sleep deprivation is
essentially a mental illness.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Totally.
ELISE LOEHNEN: And I
think it puts everything
in a different context.
I mean, it creates crisis too.
And there's nothing-- it
sucks, because there's
nothing to really do about
it when you're trying-- when
you have kids who don't sleep.
But I think even
just remembering
that in the back of your mind--
AMY SHAMUS: It's not permanent.
ELISE LOEHNEN: --that
it's not permanent,
but that it is pernicious,
helps in terms of understanding
what also might be going on.
AMY SHAMUS: Thank you all
the people on the Dory
for asking these very
personal questions.
I'm realizing why
maybe people in person
didn't want to ask so many
questions and everyone's not
as open as I am to talk
about all this stuff.
But a huge thank you
to you guys for coming
from LA and from New York.
Every Thursday
Goop has a podcast.
Elise is usually hosting,
unless it's Gwyneth herself.
So I'm sure you have a lot of
interesting guests coming up.
And there are some
other great podcasts
that are in relationship to
being a parent, and hormones,
and whatnot.
So please check those
out if you haven't.
And then obviously, Catherine,
thank you so much for coming.
And when I'm in New
York, I certainly
am coming to the Motherhood
Center, no matter what.
And I would encourage
other people
and to our New York
Googlers who are
listening to go visit as well.
And is the best way to do that
just to visit your website?
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Yeah.
AMY SHAMUS: And is
there an email alias,
or pick up the phone and call?
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Yeah, you can call.
We have an info site.
You'll get to Paige Bellenbaum,
who's our program director.
We'll be happy to
have you come and see.
AMY SHAMUS: Great.
CATHERINE BIRNDORF: Figure
out what we can do for you.
AMY SHAMUS: And
then a new book in--
CATHERINE BIRNDORF:
Yeah, next year.
AMY SHAMUS: --a year.
Thank you, guys.
Thanks, everyone, for coming.
ELISE LOEHNEN: Thank you.
AMY SHAMUS: Yay.